Welcome to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Danish cultural life, Episode One: literature, from the runes to the Romantic poets.
In Denmark, culture and everyday life belong together.
The towns, the landscape, the schools, the technology, the science, the art, and the ways Danes meet each other have come about through a long cultural history.
Danish culture has roots back to the time when the first people settled here.
You can still find jewellery and everyday objects from the oldest times and sense the life that was once lived in Denmark.
In the landscape we see traces of the oldest burial mounds and large fortress sites.
The culture of the kings and the nobility also stands out, with castles and manor houses everywhere in Denmark.
The lives and everyday lives of the broad layers of the population have also, through many centuries, marked the country's culture.
Their work has shaped the landscape, and the culture and manners in workplaces in Denmark.
In more recent times, when the welfare state really developed in the second half of the 1900s, it was considered important to strengthen cultural life, science and art.
An active cultural life was regarded as the precondition for the individual's well-being.
Art and culture were seen as the basis of democracy, and art was allowed to provoke and question accepted truths.
Even though not everyone often goes to the theatre or reads many books, art and culture create a social life that benefits the whole population.
The welfare state has therefore promoted cultural life, and thereby also helped make Denmark internationally known within several art forms.
This chapter covers six areas: literature, visual art and sculpture, music, architecture and design, performing arts, and film.
Not all important artists are mentioned.
Danish art history has traces all the way back to the Stone Age.
Here is pottery in the form of the so-called Skarpsalling vessel, which was made around 3,200 years before Christ.
Let's begin with literature.
The oldest literature in Denmark is written in Old Norse with runes, the letters of the Viking Age.
The word "runes" means "secrets", and the runes were often attributed magical power.
The best-known Danish rune inscription is on Harald Bluetooth's Jelling stone from the second half of the 900s.
Here King Harald tells that he won all of Denmark and Norway for himself and made the Danes Christian.
The runic script spread all over the Nordic region, where in some places it was used long after the Latin letters were introduced.
A large part of the literature of the Middle Ages was written in Latin.
That also applies to Saxo's Danish history, Gesta Danorum, "The Deeds of the Danes", from the beginning of the 1200s.
Saxo lived from about 1160 to 1208.
The work was meant to show that Denmark was a country in its own right, independent of the Germans, and that Denmark's king at the time, Valdemar the Great, who reigned from 1131 to 82, was the country's rightful ruler.
Saxo tells Danish history with drama, imagination and humour.
Another important work from early literary history is King Christian the Fourth's daughter Leonora Christina's description of her prison stay, Jammers Minde, "Memoirs of Misery", written in 1673 to 74 and published in 1869.
Leonora Christina lived from 1621 to 98.
Here she describes her long imprisonment and the accusations against her of treason.
She tells how she struggles to find meaning in life, and how she keeps an eye on everything that goes on around her.
The most prominent Danish-Norwegian author of the 1700s and the Enlightenment was Ludvig Holberg, who lived from 1684 to 1754.
Holberg wanted to promote the Enlightenment's ideals that, through enlightenment, tolerance and critical thinking, people could become freer and better human beings.
He wrote, among other things, satirical plays, comedies.
One of the most famous is Jeppe på Bjerget, "Jeppe of the Hill", from 1722, where the alcoholic Zealand peasant Jeppe is tricked into believing he is a lord of the manor.
Jeppe awakens the audience's sympathy when he asks himself why he drinks, and tells how he is beaten by his wife.
But you also look critically at Jeppe, since as a lord of the manor he is just as much a tyrant as those who usually have the power.
Danish literature from 1800 to today includes several world-famous authors.
The most famous is H.C.
Andersen, who lived from 1805 to 75 and was born in Odense.
He became especially known for his fairy tales, which have delighted both children and adults in Denmark and the rest of the world for almost two centuries.
The fairy tales have been translated into over 125 languages.
Den lille havfrue, The Little Mermaid.
Den grimme ælling, The Ugly Duckling.
Kejserens nye klæder, The Emperor's New Clothes.
Den lille pige med svovlstikkerne, The Little Match Girl.
And Grantræet, The Fir Tree.
These are among the most read.
Andersen's fairy tales have also inspired Disney's animated films, among other things the film The Little Mermaid from 1989, which Disney in 2023 remade in a new version.
His fairy tales are written for several age groups at the same time.
On the one hand, they contain the fantasy and supernatural world of children's stories.
On the other hand, they deal with subjects that are important to adults: prejudice, poverty, snobbery and double standards.
Adam Oehlenschläger, who lived from 1779 to 1850, was one of the best-known poets of National Romanticism.
National Romanticism wanted to promote everything that is particularly Danish in culture, nature and history.
Oehlenschläger wrote one of Denmark's two national anthems, "Der er et yndigt land", "There is a lovely land", in 1819.
Another of his best-known works is the poem "Guldhornene", "The Golden Horns", from 1802, which is about the discovery of two beautiful golden horns from antiquity, which were later stolen and melted down.
Steen Steensen Blicher, who lived from 1782 to 1848, was one of the first Danish authors to write about people's lives in what was then the distant and unknown Jutland, far away from the capital and the town.
He told about the thoughts, hopes and values of peasants, priests, civil servants, travelling traders and the poor.
He is known, among other things, for Brudstykker af en Landsbydegns Dagbog, "Fragments of a Village Sexton's Diary", from 1824, where the main character, a poor young man, tells about his modest life, his dreams and his unhappy love for a girl from the nobility whom he cannot have.
In Danish: a writer is a forfatter, a poet is a digter, fairy tales are eventyr, runes are runer, a hymn is a salme, and the national anthem is a nationalsang.
Here is your recap for Episode One.
His tales include Den grimme ælling, the Ugly Duckling.
Danish art history goes back to the Stone Age, for example the Skarpsalling vessel, about 3,200 years before Christ.
Runes mean "secrets"; the best-known rune inscription is the Jelling stone from the second half of the 900s.
Saxo wrote Gesta Danorum at the beginning of the 1200s.
Leonora Christina wrote Jammers Minde in 1673 to 74.
Ludvig Holberg, 1684 to 1754, wrote the comedy Jeppe på Bjerget in 1722.
H.C.
Andersen, 1805 to 75, was born in Odense, and his fairy tales are translated into over 125 languages.
Adam Oehlenschläger, 1779 to 1850, wrote "Der er et yndigt land" in 1819, and "Guldhornene" in 1802.
Steen Steensen Blicher, 1782 to 1848, wrote about Jutland, including the 1824 work about the village sexton's diary.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which king had it written on one of the Jelling stones that he made the Danes Christian?
Option A: Svend Forkbeard.
Option B: Harald Bluetooth.
Option C: Valdemar the Victorious.
[DA] Hvilken konge fik skrevet på den ene af Jellingstenene, at han gjorde danskerne (danerne) kristne?  A: Svend Tveskæg  |  B: Harald Blåtand  |  C: Valdemar Sejr
The answer is B: Harald Bluetooth.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Harald Blåtand
Question 2.
When did King Harald Bluetooth have it written on one of the Jelling stones that he made the Danes Christian?
Option A: The 900s.
Option B: The 1200s.
Option C: The 1500s.
[DA] Hvornår fik kong Harald Blåtand skrevet på den ene af Jellingstenene, at han gjorde danerne (danskerne) kristne?  A: 900-tallet  |  B: 1200-tallet  |  C: 1500-tallet
The answer is A: The 900s.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: 900-tallet
Question 3.
What is Denmark's national anthem with text by Adam Oehlenschläger called?
Option A: I Danmark er jeg født.
Option B: Vi elsker vort land.
Option C: Der er et yndigt land.
[DA] Hvad hedder Danmarks nationalsang med tekst af Adam Oehlenschläger?  A: I Danmark er jeg født  |  B: Vi elsker vort land  |  C: Der er et yndigt land
The answer is C: Der er et yndigt land.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Der er et yndigt land
Question 4.
Who wrote around the year 1200 the work Gesta Danorum, which contains stories about Denmark's history and Nordic mythology?
Option A: Saxo.
Option B: Brorson.
Option C: Ansgar.
[DA] Hvem skrev omkring år 1200 værket Gesta Danorum, der indeholder fortællinger om Danmarks hi- storie og nordisk mytologi?  A: Saxo  |  B: Brorson  |  C: Ansgar
The answer is A: Saxo.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Saxo
Question 5.
Who wrote the comedy Jeppe på Bjerget in 1722?
Option A: Klaus Rifbjerg.
Option B: Karen Blixen.
Option C: Ludvig Holberg.
[DA] Hvem skrev i 1722 komedien Jeppe på Bjerget?  A: Klaus Rifbjerg  |  B: Karen Blixen  |  C: Ludvig Holberg
The answer is C: Ludvig Holberg.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Ludvig Holberg
Question 6.
Which of the following stories was written by H.C.
Andersen?
Option A: Hans og Grete, Hansel and Gretel.
Option B: Skønheden og udyret, Beauty and the Beast.
Option C: Den grimme ælling, The Ugly Duckling.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende fortællinger er skrevet af H.C. Andersen?  A: Hans og Grete  |  B: Skønheden og udyret  |  C: Den grimme ælling
The answer is C: Den grimme ælling, The Ugly Duckling.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Den grimme ælling
That's the end of this part.
Well done.